-Our next guest
are world-famous magicians
and the longest-running
headliners
in Las Vegas history.
-History!
-History.
Their CW show,
"Penn and Teller: Fool Us,"
airs Friday nights at 8:00 p.m.
Please welcome Penn and Teller!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Good to see you.
-Gotta say,
I'm so glad you said,
"The longest running show
in the history of Las Vegas."
-In the history of Las Vegas.
-That way, we're competing
with Sinatra and Elvis
and winning.
-Is that right?
-We've run longer
than anyone ever in Las Vegas.
-You're at the Rio, right?
-Yeah, yeah.
-For over 20 years.
-Over 20 years.
Headliners all the time, yep.
-That's un--
-In the conveniently named
Penn and Teller Theater.
-Wow!
That's well-deserved, buddy.
-What are the chances of that?
-Since we've had you on,
you've always been there.
You were even there before,
by the way, in Vegas.
You were there
for 10 years before that.
-Yeah, there's --
we've been there for 30 years.
-Another record-breaking thing.
-Your CW show,
"Penn and Teller: Fool Us,"
was just renewed
for a 10th season,
making it the longest-running
magic show in TV history.
-There you go!
[ Cheers and applause ]
There you go.
-History yet again.
-History, history.
-Las Vegas history, TV history.
Sorry. I really put
some oomph in there.
-The downside of that means
that we have written, like,
I think, 150 magic tricks
to close "Fool Us."
We've written a lot of magic.
-Do people come up to you
all the time
and want to show you tricks?
-Well, yeah.
Well, that's
how "Fool Us" started, you know?
Vegas is the magic capital
of the world.
Magicians would come to Vegas,
come to our show.
They'd go backstage and say,
"Hey, have you seen this?"
And they would just
look at Teller,
and if he kind of went, "Oh,"
they'd go, "Oh, great!
We fooled them!"
And if we went,
"Mm, that's okay,"
they would go, "No, no."
So we kind of liked
that backstage thing,
and that's what
"Fool Us" grew out of.
-Yeah.
And then how do you --
but then how do you keep
coming up with new tricks?
Once you've seen it all,
you go, "Oh."
-What we've doing lately is,
we'll go
and take really old tricks,
like wicked old,
like public domain...
-Okay.
-...and then working with those
until they turn into something
we think is --
We're gonna show you tonight
the trick we started with,
we'll teach you how to do that,
then we'll show you the trick
we ended up with, okay?
-That's what I'm talking about.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-So the trick we started with...
-Okay.
-...is a trick called the
doughnut on the ribbon trick,
which is a rather prosaic name,
but I didn't name it.
You have your friend just --
You can come over here.
Just thread a doughnut
onto a ribbon. Okay?
-Okay.
-Then you have them
hold both ends.
You can hold both ends
like, hold the ribbon
where I am,
and then hold it over here.
Right?
Then you talk about
how doughnuts have integrity,
not just ethically and morally
but also structurally.
-Yeah, of course.
-You can't get
the doughnut off there.
Well, you're holding both ends.
Then you just put
a napkin over like this,
and then, lo and behold,
magically.
You pull the doughnut
off the ribbon.
And, see, your friend
can examine the doughnut.
It's totally legit.
It's righteous.
They can examine the ribbon,
which is totally legit,
righteous,
Nothing fishy about the props.
[ Laughter ]
And they can also
examine the napkin,
which has nothing unusual
about it whatsoever.
-Now...
-Wow.
-...you might want
to do that at home.
And if you want to,
it's really simple.
We're gonna
teach you the trick.
There's no magic moves at all.
First part, totally legit.
You just thread the doughnut
onto the ribbon. Okay?
And then you hold both ends
like you did before.
Now watch this.
No magic moves, nothing.
While you're talking
about integrity, you cop a dupe.
So you have a duplicate doughnut
over here.
It's under the napkin.
No magic moves.
-Okay.
-Then you come over here,
and then when you're
under the napkin,
we showed you
another napkin.
Just rip it apart,
and you hand them the duplicate.
-Okay.
-And then while they're
examining this,
you just eat the evidence.
[ Laughter ]
So you end up totally clean.
-Yeah, brilliantly done.
-So, we looked at this trick,
and we thought, "What could we
do to make this a new trick?"
And we thought the most
important part of this
is the shape of the doughnut.
So what else has that shape?
And the answer comes back,
how about an inner tube?
Essentially the same shape
as a doughnut,
also has the integrity.
Okay?
Now we'll have
Nathan Santucci come out here,
and we're gonna thread
the inner tube onto a rope.
Now, just you can grab that side
over there that Nathan has.
Okay?
It's the same trick, right?
-I feel bad for Teller, but,
yeah.
-You got one end,
I get the other end, right?
And then we've got
an inner tube on there.
The audience understands
everything about that, right?
-Yeah.
-And then Teller comes out
with the same napkin.
[ Laughter ]
-Now you know
how the trick is done.
-Jimmy's got one end.
I've got the other end.
Okay?
You understand?
It's topologically impossible
to get that off there.
-Yeah.
-Same trick as the doughnut.
Same trick as the doughnut?
-Yes.
-We're holding both ends.
You're not letting go.
[ Pop! ]
Nothing fishy whatsoever.
[ Laughter ]
-The rope is entirely intact.
-Unbelievable.
And then, you can also
examine the inner tube,
and it's totally intact.
And that is --
[ Laughter ]
That is the Penn and Teller
Inner Tube Trick!
-Come on.
That's how you do it!
Penn and Teller, everybody!
-That's how it's done!
-"Penn and Teller: Fool Us"
airs Fridays at 8:00 p.m.
on The CW.
More "Tonight Show"
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.
Want me to give you
the Heimlich?